انا امل ان يكون اسبوع جيد افضل من سابقه
وايضا يجب ان اكون محدد نحن موجودين في
حرب صعبه مركبه ومعقده والي وايضا
مسؤوليتي كمستوى سياسي ان نواصل ان نقود
هذه الحرب وان نمكن نعطي الجيش الوقت
لتحقيق مهامه وان نقوم بكل شيء من اجل
اعاده المخطوفين الى الوطن هذا ما سنقوم
به وهذا ليس الوقت لكلمات كبيره هذا وقت
للعمل المصمم و وانا اطلب ان
اتضن جنود جيش الدفاع المحاربين في كل
مكان في مهمه مركبه في زمن صعب من
يعرف ساحات القتال يعرف كيف هذه الصعوبه
وايضا من اجلنا ويقون امامنا وهكذا سيحدث
هذه الحرب ك
وصعبه القتال سكون مستمر والاهداف يجب ان
نحققها يجب ان
نضمن ان نعيد المخطوفين وايضا مصممين على
المدى طويل من اجل ان نحقق كل الاهداف
التي حددناها فكره حماس كفكره خاطئه
واسرائيل المزدهره والمتطوره هي الامر
الجيد وهذا ما نقوم به ان شاء الله سيكون
هناك الانتصار لنا في كل شيء